>> We're recording by the way.
>> Oh, hi, hi.
I'm Barbara Kiviat of TIME magazine.
This is Michael Arrington of TechCrunch.
You have a question?
>> What do you think is the most exciting
innovation, development over
the next decade that will help improve the
state of the world?
>> Michael?
>> The cure for cancer.
>> In the next decade?
I like that about you, you think big.
>> Oh, we're to assume that they're going
to do whatever we're saying?
>> Yeah, it's not what's nice.
>> You got YouTube HD now, right?
And she's tracking a story, that's why she's
half-here.
>> I think --
>> After YouTube HD, it's got to be a cure
for cancer.
>> I think it's going to be something to do
with water purification.
>> See?
That's a good answer.
>> Anything in particular that you've seen
that is really going to make
a difference?
>> Oh, I didn't realize that would be a follow-up
question.
>> It's a good answer.
>> Something with filtration.
We already have those tubes you know, you
just feel that like that's --
clean drinking water is sort of a very -- something
with
infrastructure, something very unsexy but
of incredible importance,
too.
>> More corn by-products would be good to
feed more people would be
good.
We need to grow more corn.
>> You know, I wish corn were in more of our
food.
>> We should maybe grow it in our own backyards.
>> But how can you top the straw water purification
thing?
>> That already exists.
But something a little more --
>> But what about you?
>> A cure for cancer.
>> What one in particular?
>> Some of the clean energy companies are
starting to actually make
energy cheaply without government paying for
it so we'll see if some of
the tech pioneers here, especially the solar
stuff.
>> I talked to a guy earlier today --
>> E-solar or something like that, doing some
really interesting
things, mirrors making water hot.
>> Because, I mean, solar's always been really
expensive to produce.
>> There's this guy in India, whose name I
don't remember, which is
unfortunate, but his company basically -- Sealco
or something like
that -- basically helps finance, you know,
street venders, folks like
that, resources in India in order to buy solar
panels and then use that
to either their, you know, light their cart
or their businesses or
their homes.
But the insight is that they partner with
local financial institutions
in order to do the sort of --
>> Where do you think ultimately the innovation
is going to come from?
I mean you mentioned -- is it going come out
of places like traditional
capitals, like Silicon Valley, or is
it going to come out of places
where you don't expect to see innovation like
India, China, et cetera?
>> Well, a lot of the panel yesterday and
The Carlyle Group was sort of
talking about how, you know, private investors
how Silicon Valley this
[INAUDIBLE] to China, India for tomorrow's
technology.
>> All right. Cool.
Thanks, guys, come by again.
>>Thanks.
>> It's awesome what you're doing here.